Today's news is not unexpected.
In the year since Harry and Meghan made their last appearance...
...at a formal royal engagement at Westminster Abbey,...
...the gulf between them and the rest of Harry's family has grown ever wider.
The couple had bought a house in California,...
...negotiated deals with US media companies...
...and made it clear that they relish their new life.
At midday today, Buckingham Palace confirmed...
...that they would not be returning as working members of the royal family.
So, one of the Royal Family's most popular members, a man for whom over the years,...
...there's been great sympathy and admiration, now faces a very different future.
The way back to royal duty has been closed.
He can never again wear a military uniform.
Harry's future lies in California with his wife and family.